Okay, mit Ihren Erlaubnissen. Ich würde gerne einmal kurz mir vorstellen.
Mein Name ist Dili Rubabairak, ich bin 26 Jahre alt.
Ungefähr seit einem Jahr bin ich in Deutschland.
Ich habe hier mit Errads im Rahmen des Erradsungsprogramms hergekommen.
Und ich habe drei Institutionen gemacht.
Mein Prüfung ist am Ende dieses Monats.
Okay.
Sobald ich eine Fachärztin bin?
Nein, ich habe noch nie gearbeitet.
Okay, alles klar.
Direkt nach dem Abschluss habe ich hier gekommen.
Okay, ich möchte alles klar.
Gut, dann fangen wir an.
Okay, ich mache erstes Mal, habe ich ein bisschen Angst.
Aber ja, ich habe Angst.
Wir machen eine Ruhe, ganz eine Ruhe.
Ja, okay.
Danke schön.
Okay, ich fange an.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Bayrak.
Ich bin auf diese Station als Estanusentätich.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bitte unterblicken Sie mich, wenn Sie mich verstehen oder wenn Sie Fragen haben.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre Beschwerden erzählen,
ich würde gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Müller.
Martin Müller.
Martin Müller, ja.
Herr Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
42.
Mhm, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. Januar 1982.
1. Januar 1982.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ein Mitte 72 groß.
72.
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Und wie ungefähr 75 Kilogramm?
75 Kilogramm.
Ja, Herr Müller.
Was führt Sie zu uns? Wie kann Ihnen helfen?
Ja, also ich habe seit ungefähr jetzt 24 Stunden schon seit gestern
habe ich Übelkeit erbrechen und auch ein bisschen durchverlässig gesagt.
Mhm.
Ja, haben Sie früher eine Beschwerden gehabt oder ist das erst mal behoffend?
Ich habe das schon mal ein paar Mal gehabt, aber das war in meiner Kindheit.
So schlimm habe ich das noch nie gehabt.
Okay, es war Kindheit.
Mhm.
Übelkeit erbrechen und Durchfall.
Ja, wie viel Mal haben Sie erbrochen?
Ja, dreimal habe ich unterbrochen seit gestern.
Mhm, dreimal.
Wie sagt die Erbrochener aus? War es Blut oder es war nur ein normaler Mahl?
Nein, das war einfach gallisch und was ich gegessen habe.
Mhm.
Normaler Mahl, okay.
Und Durchfall, wie oft haben Sie das gemacht?
Sturz.
Ja, bestimmt schon seit gestern jetzt ungefähr 15, 16 Mal.
15 Mal, ja.
Wie war die Konsistenz und Farbe von Sturz?
Die Wasser.
Wie Wasser?
Mhm.
Haben Sie Blut gesehen?
Nein.
Okay, nein.
Mhm.
Ja, verstehe.
Und haben Sie Schmerzen am Bauch?
Ich habe Kräfte, ja.
Ich habe richtige kaltbarige Schmerzen.
Mhm.
Ja.
Ja, okay.
Und wo sind diese Schmerzen?
Ganz am Bauch oder bestehende Punkte?
Ja, eigentlich im ganzen Bauch, aber eher so mittig, in der Mitte.
Ganz am Bauch, Mitte.
Mhm.
Ja.
Ist diese Beschwerden plötzlich angefangen, sind diese Beschwerden oder langsam?
Plötzlich, ganz plötzlich.
Mhm.
Ja, okay.
Mitte.
Und was haben Sie gegessen vor diese Beschwerden angefangen?
Haben Sie bestimmte Sachen gemacht oder?
Nein, ich war auf einer Feier gewesen, also auf einer Geburtstagsfeier und behandelt gegessen.
Geburtstagfeier.
Haben Sie eine, also immer so eine ungewöhnliche Essen gegessen?
Nein, wir haben Fleisch gegessen und wir haben Kuchen gegessen.
Fleisch und Kuchen, ja.
Mhm.
Ja, verstehe.
War das komisch geschmackt oder?
Eigentlich nicht.
Mhm.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie gereist in letzter Zeit, zum Beispiel in letzter Woche oder?
Was habe ich?
Haben Sie gereist in letzter Woche?
Ich bin gereist.
Gereist.
Ob ich im Ausland war?
Ja, oder ja, Ausland oder eine andere Platte haben Sie gereist?
Gereist.
Ob ich gereist bin, also weggeirrt, im Ausland gewesen bin, gereist bin.
Ja, gereist, okay, ja.
Ja, nein, ich war in Deutschland.
Mhm.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Und haben Sie viel wahr?
Ein bisschen, ja.
Haben Sie jetzt gemessen?
Ja, ich habe gemessen, das war 28,2.
38,2.
Ja, füllen Sie sich immer für dich oder?
Nee, nein.
Okay, ja okay.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und diese Bauchschmerzen, Sie sagten mir, ganzen Bauch, aber besonders im Mitte.
Ganz genau, in der Mitte, da haben wir Bauchname.
Mhm, Bauchname.
Ja, okay.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Jetzt, ich würde gerne Ihnen ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Okay.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Ja.
Gut.
Haben Sie Schweißausbrühe?
Ja, manchmal schon.
In diesen 24 Stunden, ja, seit gestern.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schütteilfrost?
Nein.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Impfstatus?
Ich glaube, der ist aktuell.
Okay.
Mhm.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit Kilo abgenommen oder zugenommen?
Ja, gesagt gestern bestimmt.
Ob ich in Toilette war.
Mhm, ja.
Können Sie Essen oder Trinken?
Ja, aber ich breche das so fort, ja.
Und da tue ich mal sehr viel.
Ja, verstehe.
Mhm.
Okay.
Also jetzt Sie haben Appetitlosigkeit wegen des Öbelkaltes?
Nein, ich habe keine Appetitlosigkeit, ich kann nur nicht Essen.
Aber?
Ja, verstehe, okay.
Mhm.
Ja, okay.
Jetzt gucken wir Ihre Vorgeschichte.
Haben Sie manche wichtige Vorerkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Superkrankheit oder Bluthoffdruck?
Nein, ich habe gar nichts, ich habe nur ein Reflex.
Mhm.
Ja, nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Magenschon, wenn ich einerbe.
Magenschon.
Mhm.
Magenschon, wie ist diese Medikamente?
Oder ist...
Omeprazol.
Omeprazol, nur einmal täglich, richtig?
Ja, auch nicht immer.
Ja, verstehe, nicht immer.
Mhm.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
20 Milligramm.
Mhm.
Ja, okay.
Nehmen Sie eine andere Medikamente ein?
Regalmethyroda Baibedars.
Ja, wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe, nehme ich Ibuprofen,
oder so, ansonsten nichts.
Mhm.
600 Milligramm oder?
400.
Mhm.
Ja, okay.
Ja, haben Sie Allergie gegen bestimmte Medikamente
oder bestimmte Nahrungsmittel?
Nein.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Unverzwecklichkeit gegen zum Beispiel Fruktozer, Laktose
oder...
Nein.
Ja.
Leben, jetzt gucken wir Ihre Familiengeschichte.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja.
Leiden Ihre Eltern an wichtige Mancher vor Erkrankungen?
Ja, die haben beide Bluthochdruck.
Mhm.
Und meine Mutter hat noch eine Schilddrösenunterfunktion.
Und mein Vater ist Frustratakation.
Mhm.
Ist das Behandelt würde, oder?
Das wird behandelt, ja.
Aha.
Okay.
Ja, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Einzelkind.
Haben Sie schon mal Operation gehabt?
Nein, noch nie.
Mhm.
Okay.
Jetzt gucken wir Ihre Gewohnheiten.
Rachen Sie oder haben Sie schon geracht?
Ich rache ja.
Mhm. Wie viel Zigarette rachen Sie täglich?
Halbe Schachtel ungefähr.
Ja. Seit wann rachen Sie?
Ja, ich habe schon mit 18 Jahren ungefähr angefangen.
18 Jahre.
18 Jahre angefangen.
Genau.
Ja, okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, am Wochenende.
Am Wochenende.
Was trinken Sie?
Kommt immer drauf an. Cocktails, Bier, das, was da ist.
Mhm.
Ja, Glas oder Flasche?
Wie viel?
Unterschiedlich.
Unterschiedlich. Ja, okay.
Ja.
Bitte, nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine routine Frage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen ein oder haben Sie schon kontaktiert?
Kann alles.
Nehmen Sie ein oder nur einmal probiert?
Nehmen Sie ein.
Wie oft?
Kommt drauf an, am Wochenende meistens.
Meistens, woher nehmt ihr?
Meistens woher nehmt ihr?
Und was haben Sie gesagt?
Am meisten am Wochenende.
Am meisten.
Ja, okay.
Und was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Bürokaufmann.
Bürokaufmann.
Mhm.
Haben Sie Stress beim Arbeit?
Ja.
Ja, ich kann mir vorstellen.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin allein lebend.
Allein lebend.
Haben Sie Partnerin?
Ja.
Mhm.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Mhm.
Ja.
Haben Sie Stress im Sozialleben?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ja.
Mhm.
Diese Geburtstagfeier, waren Sie gestern?
Oder wann waren Sie dieser Feier?
Das war vor drei Tagen.
Vor drei Tagen.
Ja, Herr Müller.
Das hat alles gestern angefangen.
Aber die Geburtstagsfeier war vor drei Tagen.
Das heißt, das war heute Sonntag.
Das war heute Sonntag.
Das war am Donnerstag.
Nein, am Freitag, Entschuldigung.
Und drei Tage.
Okay.
Freitag.
Ja.
Herr Müller, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Jetzt mache ich eine kurze Zusammenfassung.
Wir haben seit gestern über Kalt,
Abdehung und Durchfall.
Sie haben ähnliche Beschevarden
in letzter Zeit noch nie gehabt.
Nur es war am Kindheit.
Und sie haben drei Mal Albrochen.
Und die Albrochen sah wie normal magend
und hatte Essenreste auch.
Und sie haben ungefähr 15 Mal Durchfall gehabt.
Und es war wie Wasser.
Und sie haben kein Blut gesehen.
Und sie haben auch Barschmerzen.
Es wie wie Krämpfe.
Und diese Schmerzen im ganzen Bauch, besonders im Mitte.
Und sie waren vor drei Tagen
in einer Geburtstagfeier.
Und sie haben hier Fleisch und Kuchen gegessen.
Und sie haben in letztes Mal nicht aus Land gereist.
Und jetzt sie haben Fieber.
Und es war 38,2 Grad.
Und außerdem sie haben Schweißausrüber her.
Und jeder Appetit ist normal.
Aber wenn sie essen oder trinken,
danach machen sie es auch.
Und sie haben auch Fieber.
Und sie haben keine Verkrankungen.
Außerdem reflekt.
Sie nehmen manchmal Omepadol.
Und sie rauen halbgeschachter,
seit ihrer Asthmaelämpfe.
Und sie trinken manchmal Alkohol.
Sie nehmen manchmal Drogen,
und lohe eine besonders.
Und sie sind Bürokaufmann.
Und sie trinken manchmal Alkohol.
Und sie trinken mehr Pfeil.
Und sie trinken einen Bürokaufmann.
Und sie haben eine Person.
Aber sie wollen alleine.
Ja.
Haben Sie Fragen oder nicht?
Ich würde gerne, was das ist,
und ich würde gerne etwas helfen.
Was habe ich denn jetzt?
Was ich denn jetzt?
Nein, denken Sie nicht so schlimm an.
Jetzt haben wir noch eine Gespräche durchgeführt und erst mal, ich würde gerne Körperle untersuchen.
Danach werde ich für Stabilität ab.
Sobald ich die Ergebnisse bekomme, werde ich wieder bei Ihnen und werden wir Ihre Situation besprechen.
Okay.
Und von Herrn.
Für erst was besprechen?
Ja, genau.
Ja, okay.
Brauchen Sie Zeit oder möchten Sie weitermachen?
Okay, zwei Minuten.
Okay, schneller.
Das wäre besser, wenn Sie bitte im Insel seid.
Okay, danke schön.
Hat jemand, in der, in der, in irgendwelchen Fragen, sehr passiert?
Ich habe eine Frage. Sie möchten?
Ja, bitte.
Herr Müller, haben Sie eine Konzentrationsstörung oder Bewusstsein Veränderung seit gestern?
Nee, aber ich bin total schwach auf den Beinen. Also ich kann kaum stehen. Mir geht es überhaupt nicht gut.
Ist Wasser lassen, vermindert oder gar nicht?
Nein.
Oder okay.
Okay.
Und ab der Netheilnehmer der Partie einige Heilnehmer diese gleiche Wischwerden oder nur Sie?
Ja, tatsächlich. Meine Freundin hat das auch und meine Freundin hat das auch. Ja.
Okay, danke Ihnen.
Gibt es noch Fragen?
Ja.
Sag ich, ob ich heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen habe.
Ich würde gerne von meinen Patienten erzählen. Ich würde gerne von meinen Patienten vorstellen. Darf ich?
Bitte schön, ich warte. Ich erzuge.
Danke schön.
Martin Müller ist 42 Jahre alt. Erster, erster 82 geboren.
Und 1,72 Meter und 75 Kilogramm. Erster, erster, erster, seit gestern, seit gestern angefangen.
Nausea Emesis und Dierre bei uns vor. Er berichtete, dass die einigen Wischwerden in letzter Zeit nicht gehabt haben.
Er hatte 3 Mal Emesis und 15 Mal Dierre gehabt.
Beide war ohne Blutung. Und er berichtete auch noch, er habe Barschmetzen im ganzen Bauch, Koli-Kartik.
Unser Patient berichtete, vor 3 Tagen war er im Feier. Und hier er habe Fleisch und Puchen gegessen.
Und seine Freundin hatte elche Beschwerden. Und die Fragen nach Reise ins Ausland, die Syri, die Somni, Schüttelfrost und Inapetanz wurden verneint.
Und als Vorerkrankungen, leider er an nur Reflexkrankheit, dagegen nehmen er um den Pazol 20 Milligramm bei Bedarf.
Und außerdem diese Medikamente, nehmen er ein bei Bedarf, ich bin Prof. 400 Milligramm, nehme er im Prof. 400 Milligramm bei Bedarf ein.
Allergien bei ihm nicht bekannt. Die Familienannamnese ergab atelierliche Hypertony und Beninprostata hyperplasi bei Vater.
Und atelierliche Hypertony und Hypotheude, beide Mutter, er haben noch nie Operation gehabt.
Und er sei Rauha und er Rauhe 12 Pack, er die Rauhe seit dem 18. Lebensjahr, halbbeschachtel täglich.
Das bedeutet, die Nikotinkonsum ist 12 Packiers. Er trinke gelegenen Alkohol, er nehme gelegenen, besonders anwohlenen Drogen ein und er sei Bürokaufmann vom Beruf Cannabis.
Er sei Bürokaufmann vom Beruf, er habe Stress beim Arbeit und er wohne alleine, habe er Partnerin, er habe keine Kinder.
Ja, das war es.
Okay, sehr gut. Wie geht es ihm? Ist er sehr schwach auf den Beinen?
Ja.
Er trinken oder kann er nicht trinken?
Er sagte, er fühle sich schwach und er habe keine Appetitlosigkeit. Er kann essen und trinken, aber nach dem Essen oder trinken muss er wieder erbrochen.
Erbrechen oder hat sofort Durchfall, ne?
Ja.
Wie was glauben Sie denn, was er hat?
Er hat Gastroenteritis wegen dieser Fleisch- oder Kuchen.
Im Paltier habe er gegessen.
Ja.
Als die Fernsehdiagnose, mein Verdachtdiagnose ist Gastroenteritis, als die Fernsehdiagnose kommen, kommen nur Enteritis oder ein Pankreatitis in Betra.
Okay. Was ist mit chronisch-entsündlichen Darmerkrankungen? Morbus Kohl, Kohl-Dies Ulzer-Rosa?
Ja, natürlich. Wegen dieser 15-mal Durchfall habe ich gleich gedacht.
Aber diese Beschwärter ist sehr akut.
Seit gestern habe ich, habe er die Beschwerden.
Und wenn er früher ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt habe, können wir denken, diese chronische Darmerkrankungen.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten jetzt?
Jetzt erstmal, ich würde gerne Körperlöhntesuffungen machen, besonders im Bauch.
Und wegen dieser Durchfall, er habe wahrscheinlich viel Flüssigkeit verlust.
Und ich muss gucken, die Tonus der Haut.
Und erstmal, ich würde gerne kontrollieren, habe er Flüssigkeit, niedriger Flüssigkeit.
Und also, ja, dann erstmal, ja, danach mache ich Blutabnahme, besonders die Entzündung der Parameter, CRP und Prochastonium.
Erst mal CRP ist genug, ja. Ich kann diese Parameter kontrollieren.
Und wegen dieser Durchfall, ich würde gerne Stuhlfultur machen.
Stuhlprobe abnehmen, Stuhlprobe.
Ja, Stuhlprobe abnehmen, ja.
Aber Sie nehmen auch noch Blutbildabnehmerwerte, Leberwerte.
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig.
Ja, aber nur sagen Sie, wir haben kein Kredit, müssen Sie auch die Pause mit abnehmen.
Die Werte mit abnehmen, ne?
Das machen wir aber keine genauesen Regeln.
Und was machen Sie denn therapeutisch?
Therapeutisch?
Erst mal Flüssigkeit, Infusion geben.
Und dann, wenn Stuhlprobe gibt es bestimmte Erreger, wenn dies gegen diese Erreger ein Antibiotische gibt.
Dann kann ich diese Medikamente verabreichen.
Und außerdem, ja, erst mal, die Beide ist genug.
Welche Erreger könnten das denn sein?
Was glauben Sie, welche Erreger?
Ein ganz wichtiger gibt es.
Nourverous macht Überkeit und Diarrhe.
Und vielleicht Ecole.
Ja, was gibt es noch?
Wenn Blut gibt, dann ist es kein Monella, es ist kein Lästchen, aber es ist kein Blut.
Man muss immer auch an Salmonellen denken, ganz wichtig.
Aber das ist erst mal nicht so wichtig, sondern die müssen in Flüssigkeit geben,
dass er wieder zu Kräften kommt, eine Infusionstherapie und gegebenenfalls auch Schmerztherapie,
wenn er starke Schmerzen hat, etwas Übelkeit gegen Durchfall geben.
Und dann muss man die Stuhlproben abwarten.
Wenn es eine Salmonellose ist oder ein Norovirus ist, kann man eh nicht viel machen.
Man könnte bei sehr schweren Verlauf bei Salmonellen zum Beispiel ein Antibiotikum geben.
Bei Norovirus geht das nicht, haben wir nichts, gibt es nichts, dann muss man abwarten.
Aber was müssen Sie bei Norovirus machen?
Müssen Sie den Patienten isolieren?
Generell bei Brechdurchfall im Krankenhaus,
müssen Sie den Patienten isolieren, nicht vergessen.
Wenn Sie den Verdacht, dass wir Norovirus haben, immer isolieren.
Aber bei ihm ist das, glaube ich, eher kein richtiger Brechdurchfall.
Das hat er nicht gesagt, sondern er hat nur dreimal erbrochen,
aber dafür 15-mal war er auf Toilette.
Wahrscheinlich ist einfach eine normale Gastrinteritis,
aber es kann auch eine Salmonellose sein.
Er hat Fleisch gegessen, er hat Kuchen gegessen, wo auch Eier mit drin sind.
Man weiß es nicht.
Genau, das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht.
Ihr Deutsch ist sehr gut, muss man sagen, wirklich.
Also gutes Deutsch für einen, dafür, dass Sie nur ein Jahr hier sind.
Also sehr gut, muss man sagen.
Auch die Analyse fand ich gut.
Dankeschön.
Gibt es uns Fragen?
War ja ein ganz einfacher Fall, weil nicht so schwer,
war einfach eine normale Gastrinteritis mit Verdacht auch Salmonellose.
Bei Salmonellen.
Weiche Antibiotika, Amoxicillin.
Ich bin mich nicht der herweiche Antibiotika.
Also Flurischine Lone, das kann man geben.
Oder man kann natürlich auch Zerfallosporine geben.
Das macht man meistens.
Und man kann auch die Anerobia,
gegebenenfalls mit Metroneda-Zol, mit behandeln werden,
welche da sein sollten.
Gibt es irgendwelche Fragen?
Wenn nicht, dann wünsche ich einen schönen Sonntag.
Für einen.